qu'il s'agisse de reproduire une oeuvre
d'art classique avec des objets tous les
jours
de créer une oeuvre et spontanée en 48
heures top chrono ou encore de créer une
sculpture avec des objets qui nous
entourent les défis pour exprimer sa
créativité en ligne ne manquent pas
depuis le début du confinement
les musées aussi se prêtent au jeu en
faisant preuve d'inventivité de la crise
peut émerger la création qu'est ce qui
change
comment ça change pour nous bien sûr
mais surtout le centre fille croit que
la parole des artistes doit être
entendue en ces temps de crise
des projets que minute par minute invite
les artistes à créer une oeuvre en 60
secondes peu importe le moyen
d'expression
c'est très important et vital une
certaine compréhension humains sont tous
les niveaux que les artistes sont
capables exprimés et réfléchir
peut-être d'une manière où il ya
incompréhension universel le musée de la
civilisation de québec entend ajouter
ces témoignages précieux à ses
collections
d'abord c'est dans une optique de
pérennisation bien sûr pour assurer la
mémoire de ça mais on va essayer de
l'utiliser éventuellement soit dans une
exposition virtuelle soit dans une
exposition même physique
il observe qu inspiré par l'air du temps
les oeuvres soumises évolué au fil des
jours qui passent dans les premières
semaines premier jour évidemment il y
avait surtout des ja qui nous parlait de
l'anxiété de l'incertitude de
l'angoissent de plus en plus on sent que
les gens je ne sais pas qui a aidé la
once en l'espoir les beaux jours le
printemps est la reprise la relance
alors on sent que la société est en
train de se dire ça va bien aller
un virage numérique forcé qui laissera
des traces positive et créative et syna
bien alexandre chartier radio canada
montréal